die fellows cadres this is when we just
peppers wit caruso no fire
the bit more than two years ago the deep
mind guy simplemente afterwards by him you
can play guitar you breakout
to the superhuman level by looking at the
video feed that you sieger and the  new
simi die de song also the world pastor
die soriano peper is a bit more than
two years old and therefore a baby a
reference about 1000 other research
papers that's what marvel peper
this item was based on a combination of
in your network and reinforce  met
learning
duo network was used to understand the
video feed en wie enforcement learning
is there to come up with the appropriate
action this is the port de place the game
reinforcement learning is very suitable
for guests where who is in the changing
environment and who is not  to choose an
appropriate action based on their
surroundings to maximize
some sort of score disc or can be for
instance a far we've got me in a
labyrinth story men ecolutions we
have  before we interweave the helicopter
any sort of scored
keep moaning lie I do and this making
you it and work similarly to how many
molar candy thanks here on service die
in warmond
try different excellence and see if they
worked well the flash this is keep
doing that choose size
well let's try something as level of
start building is an excellent
example of time the window and ix is tim worth
in this area in the performance humor
ghibli do for a number of probl
ms and computer games with oil or by yo
r  word chaos relatively lee quickly
behind die action for instance in break
out the form is the ball live
in mediate ran message must god it will
almost immediately breaks and breaks and
increase of score this is more than
suitable for a wel image reinforcement
learning
however  this early work this perform well
done and games that required long-term
planning
has table af [ __ ] that it cane
dispatch I must this two days ago the
animal  him so close to check
select the skier i you we and they
in the morning object is a game where you
can for the screen character and aygo can
be posted box is for the red parts disc
1 is particularly the faculty
only for items refund you  meant weekend
of to import en 2 sun's one
something require slime time planning wss
mina is there views euphoria force met
learning gerätes just because the box is
still story but doesn't mean that this is the
one deadpool fear there this is a
political lonely nasty  property of the
game and to some mistakes made of in
reversible
for is so pushing the box in a
corner can make it in possible to
complete level to have a great dan de
tribe anciaux factions and see if they
say well that's not going to work you  die
so times hopeful easy to see that this
is an option musical problem
and the deep mind guys just came up with
team education argument this agents
and they solution for it like behind this
lily cole take the interesting partner
what the sna  sheet architecture is that this
use the imagination you need about 10 to
cook at not only one axel met n dry your
plans consisting of several steps and
finally tools warm dat has the greatest
expected wie word over de longueur
details information about the present
and  the medial pro single futures
end-users de wang we de molen en sammy
hoor en that i can see is a solid
first paper on this new architecture
in het kanon ready solve a problem with
seven boxes this is just an wiel
absolutely amazing work and please  note
that this is a very generous and that
can be used for en number of different
problems
this particular game was just wanna be
of demonstrating the effective
properties of this will technique de
peper contains more results and this
great read
make sure to have look so if  you enjoy
this episode please consider supporting
then minute papers on t2l this azar
available in the video discription level
also tank searching can for your generous
support na see  you next time
[Music]